[music]
the flight movements have just performed in
europe to rethink and the
exhibition is indeed large and
climate change is becoming more and more
noticeable in the poorest countries in
the world and here we have
to try to answer together with the european commission and with
the member countries
to find
i think we have all recognized that
the sector can do a lot more
than before
but you need security
there are good examples of private
investment in particular a relatively large number of
small companies are involved in the
alternative energy sector and
i think the investment here is that of  the eu
is supported very very important because
with energy in developing
countries the situation can really take clear steps
the board for exchange for the
change
the positive things in advance the works
office gave
[music]